eh ben eh ben et bah voilà ça y est nous
y revoilà xiaomi a encore frappé ça ça
c'est un monstre
on parle du xiaomi on parle du million
ultra lent je vous ai présenté le
million je vous ai présenté le mélange
light je ne vous présenterai pas le
meilleur ce pro parce qu'il n'arrivera
pas en france mais là il est l'heure de
vous parler du meilleur ultra on va
l'appeler el mondo euros c'est
absolument incroyable c'est toujours
démentiel si vous voulez quand je suis
arrivé de montrer les muscles on a
beaucoup connu xiaomi au travers d'un
smartphone de plusieurs smartphones
d'entrée milieu de gamme avec des poids
super intéressant et à partir de l'année
dernière sur le midi ils ont montré les
muscles sérieusement et son arrivée
vraiment une des smartphones qui ont
frappé fort notamment le midi ce projet
j'avais beaucoup aimé et là il arrive
avec une bête une bête complète c'est
celui là est ce celui là il coûte quand
même un petit peu moins de 1200 euros
les sur une config 12 igad ram 256 go de
stockage alors avant de se faire un tour
complet de ce qu'il est de ce qu'ils
peuvent faire des photos tous à des
vidéos wouah franchement elle monitor
regardez moi ce truc c'est hyper massif
il est énorme
hélas ce qu'on voit et ça c'est génial
là j'adore on a un écran un écran bon je
vais tout vous expliquer les détails à
quoi il sert est-ce qu'on peut fabriquer
il n'est pas tactile repérer d'en faire
ce qu'on peut faire avec
à quoi il servait déjà le format je vais
vous mettre à côté un smartphone qui
c'est dans la poche depuis un petit
moment qui est très massif c'est
l'iphone 12 promax voilà regardez les
tags dans le détail c'est absolument
démentielle il est plus grand il est un
peu moins large que l'iphone 12 pronax
alors ici on a un smartphone qui fait
quand même il sait combien celui là il
est énorme qu'elle fait j'ai pas pris
par coeur il fait 234 g nom de zeus et à
dire que je peux le prendre et j'en fais
une haltère jeu musclé à bout de bras
comme ça je peux vous assurer qu'au bout
d'un moment je vois des combats tout
genre des crampes 234 g
on parle d'un smartphone qui est très
massif mais qui ont aussi très chouette
qui est aussi très très chouette alors
c'est un design très particulier un
franchement il est grand il est gros là
vous avez un des bords de fous furieux
regardez alors on parle de ultra tout
est ultra dans ses smartphones
le prix le poids les photos les vidéos
tout est ultra c'est un choix qui est un
peu intéresse un choix qui est super
intéressant parce que c'est une pièce à
part de ce smartphone ils ont vraiment
fait le choix de venir vous faire un
espèce de blocs énormes incrusté ici
alors une fois que vous l'aurez protégés
bien évidemment tout ça va disparaître
parce que oui c'est un smartphone qui
fournit à protéger et c'est justement ce
matin qu'il faut venir protéger grâce
notamment aux coques de mon partenaire
rhino chez vous avez des coques un peu
classique en carbone mais ce qui nous
intéresse nous eh bien ce sont les
différentes coques dans différents
univers
on va avoir du assassination classroom
on va avoir du fortnight on avoir dû
fairy tail on va avoir dû annuler tort
on va avoir également des coques
approuvé par la nasa
on va avoir également d'école dans
l'univers du sport avec les chicago
bulls combat notamment avoir des
cracheurs de démos des knicks pouvez
garder votre smartphone apparent ou bien
évidemment venir mettre des bacs play et
à l'arrière très sympa dans plein
d'univers notamment de league of legends
qui est là et si vous aimez les mangas
ya une nouvelle collection one piece qui
était extrêmement attendu qui arrive
enfin chez rhinochill je vous évite tous
les liens en bas d'un description cette
collection notamment one piece et bien
il sera disponible pour votre mii aux
ultras et ça c'est la très très bonne
nouvelle donc cliquer sur le lien en bas
dans la description ça vous emmène sur
une page pour venir vous enregistrer
pour être tenu au courant des ex aequo
qui arriveront alors sherin auch il ya
des coqs mais ya pas que des colts vous
avez également des attaques screen
protecteur pour venir protéger l'écran
de votre smartphone et ça c'est la très
très bonne nouvelle vous avez également
des accessoires avec des câbles censés
du lightning c'est chez apple mais vous
pouvez également avoir plein
d'accessoires pour votre smartphone
android donc une fois de plus le lien
est en bas dans la description je vous
invite à venir cliquez dessus et vous
bénéficiez grâce aux codes grevin t1
d'un code de 5% de remise pour votre
prochain achat sur le site de rhinau
shield et ça c'est une très bonne
nouvelle
mais au delà du fait de le protéger à
regarder ça c'est quand même hyper mouse
alors votre écran ici il est super
intéressant parce que c'est un écran
notification il vous servira aussi bien
pour venir voir leurs lorsque vous êtes
comme ça que lorsque vous êtes dans
votre mode photo vous allez ici dans vos
paramètres et vous venez là
il avait affiché écran arrière aperçu de
l'écran il a regardé là vous l'avez donc
là effectivement je suis bien sûr ma
caméra arrière c'est à dire que je peux
le prendre comme ça il dira je fais une
photo ob paf
ici j'ai un mini écran amoled de 1,1
pouces 294 par 126 pixels salle espèce
de faux carré en fait vous allez pouvoir
avoir vos notifications à l'intérieur
vous et pouvoir afficher l'heure quand
vous avez un appel s'adresse affichée
enfin voila c'est vraiment une petit
écran de notification un peu comme ce
qu'on a vu chez samsung sur le samsung
galaxy z flip petit écran de
notification quand il est plié alors là
il n'est pas payé les dom et ses
pratiques
après bon le reste est assez classique à
vous connaissez un grand écran qui est
perforé ici les boutons sur le côté le
capteur d'empreintes digitales sur
l'écran tiroirs de cartes sim qui est
situé là vous avez ici de l'usbc un haut
parleur qui est là on en parle dans
quelques instants sur le côté si vous
n'avez rien vous avez un deuxième haut
parleurs qui situent juste sur le dessus
ici alors je sais pas si vous le voyez
mais c'est écrit noir sur blanc signés
arman cardon son harman kardon et vous
avez ici de l'infrarouge
alors maintenant il ya un autre truc
assez intéressant ici c'est l'écran
alors l'écran il est plutôt cool
une fois de plus on est dans le très
haut de gamme chez xiaomi on a un écran
amoled iy626 80 ans poussée du quad hd +
3200 pas 1440 pixels et on a surtout dû
120 hertz adaptatif point de vue
logiciel là je suis sur me wade 12 basé
sur un android 11 me wade 12 j'ai plein
de choses super intéressantes aime son
thème clair j'en ai déjà parlé me wade
nous à les refaire un tour sur ma petite
vidéo c'est vachement bien vous êtes en
w qhd plus à l'inter consommer davantage
de batteries li-ion powerswitch si vous
souhaitez en full hd plus au delà de ça
et ce qui m'intéresse c'est qu'ici
jeunes écran qui est super lumineux 1710
maximum ses énormes peu suivi dehors il
ya du soleil il fait beau on est au mois
de mai ya du soleil enfin
eh bien ça marche super bien la qualité
de l'écran est là la dalle est
extrêmement bien maîtrisé je trouve
vraiment vraiment bien vous avez en plus
haut taux d'échantillonnage tactile de
480 m
donc pour le gaming c'est vraiment top
dole division h dr death plus bref ici
l'écran et hop pour l'expérience de
visionnage de gaming de ce que vous
voulez il ya rien à dire ça peux pas
alors là où c'est un peu moins bien et
où là je suis un poil déçu c'est sur la
partie audio j'avais adoré l'année
hier la spatialisation est l'effet de
stéréoscopie sur le me disent pro là ils
vont proposer quelque chose
d'intéressant alors c'était moyen moyen
sur le million ce jeu trop avec la
stéréo était pas terrible
là je me dis quand je le prends comme ça
je dis au pij haut parleurs là ça va
être top
ok elle écrivait moquez vous avez lu
haut-parleurs là ça va être top donc je
vais avoir une vraie symétrie au niveau
de l'audio terme de spatialisation ça va
être bien sauf qu'en réalité c'est pas
ça du tout et pourquoi regarder je vous
mets ma vidéo teaser alors qu'on va tout
de suite on entend c'est qu'il ya du
chemin à vraiment y sont enfin tombés
franchement il ya du temps écoutez ça il
ya vraiment d'où sont maintenant on a un
vrai déséquilibre entre celui là qui est
beaucoup plus grave est celui
l'achèterai les dom regardez là je
bloque je suis là j'ai un sombre je
bloque je suis là ça fait quoi coin
regardera donc un tout ou rien sur les
hauts-parleurs vous avez sur la gauche
ici eh bien vous avez un très peu de son
vous n'avez pas un très gros volume vous
avez un spectre qui est tout petit a
s'est étouffée sur le médium là c'est
bien sûr celui de droite on a du fond
d'avoir aimant du son ça tabasse
il aurait fallu la même expérience avec
celui de gauche sur celui de droite et
là j'aurais dit oui un grand oui au
niveau de la joue donc ça s'est un peu
on soul c'est un peu dommage et on est
en dessous d'une milice pro de l'année
dernière voilà ça c'est vraiment le
bémol son expérience en termes de
performances ici bien évidemment on a un
truc qui cartonne c'est un dragon 888 12
igad ram sena lp dernière 5 ce qui
marche de mieux aujourd'hui on à 256
giga de stockage en du ffs trois points
en autant vous dire qu'en lecture
écriture la ram et compagnie on a le
combo gagnons c'est sûr qu'on est un
smartphone qui top en terme de
performance pour venir jouer à des jeux
ce soit des pnj à ce que vous voulez
c'est très réactif ça vachement bien
ouais
ça c'est bien maintenant il ya un autre
point qui est intéressant c'est que vous
avez aussi une très grosse batterie de
5000 milliampères une très grosse
batterie de 5 millions paire eur ok on
trouve des grosses batteries de 5000
milles et antérieures dont beaucoup de
smartphones c'est pas forcément un truc
qui va être le plus étonnant ce qui va
être le plus étonnant ici c'est ça qui
est intéressant c'est ce petit chiffre
là qui écrit il alors si vous levez un
bien là la halle et va se mettre là
regardez là vous verrez mieux ici c'est
du 60 7 watts vous avez un blog de
charge de 60 cette date vous leur charge
et de 0 à 100% en 36 minutes extrêmement
rapidement alors bon ok venir charger
rapidement son smartphone pourquoi pas
on va dire bon ok ça marche une fois de
plus un énième chargeur rapide
oui c'est sûr je suis d'accord avec vous
mais ce que ça permet surtout c'est en
termes d'usagés sa cote est très
rassurant pourquoi parce que lorsque
vous avez beaucoup joué regarder sur un
grand écran comme ça que vous êtes quand
même sur une dalle de 6,81 pousse ça
vient tire énormément donc autonomie ça
va pas être la meilleure
bien évidemment même si le stand dragon
888 est très bon et n'est pas très
énergivores qu'est ce que va bien faire
ce bloc de charge de 67 soit ici mais il
va le recharger rapidement il dit avant
tout vous libérer l'esprit
vous ne vous dites pas à mince je me
lève le matin j'ai plus beaucoup de
batterie vous prenez vous le branchez
vous allez vous doucher vous brosser les
dents vous déjeunez bon déjeuner avant
de vous brosser les dents on va faire
dans ce sens là et vous êtes tranquille
vous êtes reparti pour une journée une
journée me sens promène donc même si on
va pas boire ici la meilleure autonomie
on va tellement vite avec ce bloc de
charges qu'on se pose plus de questions
et puisque je vous parle dans charge
vous avez effectivement votre blog de
charge 60 7 watts mais vous avez
également de la recharge sans fil 67
watts et vous avez de la charge un
verset 10 watts dessus mais là mais là
où ça nous intéresse réellement c'est
ici sur la partie photo alors regardez
moi ça là ça devient complètement dingos
vous le voyez déjà vous avez un
téléobjectif un zoom périscopique vous
êtes ici sera 48 mégapixels on à 1,48
mégapixels ici est également sur
d'autres ultra grand-angle sont ultra
grand-angle vous ouvrez à f 2.2 avec un
champ de vision de 128 degrés tandis
qu'ici la sur votre route périscopique
et bien vous êtes sera 48 mégapixels et
ouvre à f 4 points 1 oui
zoom optique x 5 soul hybride x 10 et
vous aller jusqu'à un zoom numérique x
120 on s'en fiche du zoom x 120 à la
qualité elle est pas belle bien
évidemment mais ce que ça permettra mais
bien c'est notamment d'avoir un zoom
hébrides
bonne qualité je vous montre le résultat
dans quelques instants et vous allez
voir et vous allez voir en terme de
photos moi ça m'a bluffé votre capteur
principal 150 mégapixels qui ouvre à f
1.95 vous avez ici probablement le plus
gros capteur du marché est d'autant plus
que vous avez la technologie 4 pixels en
hausse ça va venir car ce qu'on appelle
du pixel baning c'est les regrouper
plusieurs pixels pour capter plus de
luminosité grâce à cette technologie là
on va plus loin captera plus de lumière
et notamment dans des conditions de
faible luminosité notamment pour la
photo de nuit c'est bluffant extrêmement
bluff à savoir qu'ici vous avez deux
capteurs qui sont stabilisées c'est
votre capteur principal et votre télé
objectif d'une périscopique sa part être
anormal sans quoi ce avec difficile de
venir photographier en x 120 tandis qu'à
l'avant vous avez une caméra de celle ci
va mégapixels couvre f 2.2 je peux me
faire de la vidéo en 8k 24 images par
seconde en filmant roxy qui est en train
de manger je ne sais quoi
donc ça c'est bien mais pour pouvoir
faire ça et bien il faut que je
désactive le hdr parce que si je mets le
hdr je peux filmer jusqu'en quarts
quatre cas je sais plus combien 4k à 30
images par seconde d'ailleurs c'est ce
que je tenterai de faire tout de suite
j'ai mis le hdr je suis en capter 1 30
images par seconde j'ai toujours roxy
qu'elle a toujours mon petit zoom ça se
comprend bien c'est sympa ça donc voilà
ça fonctionne c'est pas mal et avec le
hdr désactiver je monte jusqu'à quatre
cas à 60 images par seconde ce qui est
le cas tout de suite là donc là je suis
en 4 carole là une envolée de moineaux
4k à 60 images par seconde donc ça ça
fonctionne ça me va bien également au
niveau du test puis là j'ai plusieurs
vols de stabilisation chaussures de la
stabilisation proches en 1080p à 30
images par seconde c'est le max que je
puisse faire
parce qu'en fait ça va venir croquer
dans l'image soulager stabilisation
optique et électronique
là j'ai une stabilisation un peu plus
normal en tout cas un peu - poussines
mais chasse toujours en 1080p à 30
images par seconde je peux pas monter
plus l'assument sur la caméra de cette
fille en or ce qui est un peu bizarre
vous savez ce que je trouve un peu
dommage c'est qu'effectivement et bien
j'ai cet écran à l'arrière qui me permet
de voir ce que je suis en train de
vouloir photographier donc je peux me
voir en arrière je vais l'activé
directement nommé par m donc ça c'est
bien mais par contre en vidéo je peux
pas le faire et c'est un peu dommage
parce que ce que je voudrais c'est par
exemple si je prends mon smartphone et
je vais vous loguez à l'extérieur je
prends je le pose et je voudrais me voir
derrière pour profiter d'une meilleure
qualité au lieu de le faire avec la
caméra telle fille là où je vais être
d'une moins bonne qualité
voilà il y aura un sens pour l'instant
en tout cas d'un point de vue logiciel
c'est pas possible
en tout cas si c'est possible je n'ai
pas trouvé en tout cas c'est pas
possible de la même manière
que au niveau de la photo donc je pense
que c'est pas possible pour résumer vous
avez compris aux polices par honda soir
une petite devinette
dites moi dites moi à votre avis à quel
moment été prise cette photo à peu près
à quelle heure de la journée du soir
dites moi
à votre avis regardez les lumières
regarder les ont regardés tout ça je
vais vous le dire c'est assez
impressionnant en fait surtout classe a
été pris il devait être 23 heures il
faisait nuit noire et le rendu est
complètement nano alors je commence par
la photo de lui parce que c'est un truc
qui m'a vraiment surpris que j'ai trouvé
vraiment super et celle là où on va
toute la force de ce capteur de 5
mégapixels la façon dont il vit à capter
les lumières et où le viol est restituée
et la façon dont l'algorithme travail
regardez on est sur une photo sur le
capteur principal ça marche vraiment
bien si on passe sur l'ultra grand temps
on perd on perd en précision n'a aucune
stabilisation avec moi ça ne pardonne
pas même là je suis en x 2 ça marche
vraiment bien quand même
regardez-moi ça le détail à regarder ça
regardez ça c'est hyper bluffant le
détail on voit on voit les étoiles de
partout dans le ciel il ya aucun
artifice ondes et en pleine ville vous
voyez aussi bien les arbres que les
pavés que les étoiles
voilà c'est dingue je viens en fois de
dessus j'arrive à sentir les choses
calme qui sont radieux regardez on voit
bien tous les petits poils ici là c'est
c'est la force de l'algorithme c'est
vraiment bluffant laurier un côté un
petit peu un petit peu faye qui a un
côté un peu poussive bien évidemment
c'est la nuit on s'en doutera mais
malgré tout c'est là j'ai l'impression
que je suis en plein jour presque
c'est juste pas possible et ce à la
regardez moi cette scène alors j'ai un
éclairage derrière moi mais on parle
bien d éclairage public
on ne parle pas d'autre chose j'ai tout
un ciel étoilé je vois bien mes arbres
j'ai l'impression d'avoir une vue qui
est une photo retouchée
alors qu'elle est partout chez l'algo
est poussive on peut dire tout ce qu'on
veut derrière mais ce qui est sûr c'est
que c'est extrêmement efficace même là
j'ai essayé de prendre le ciel bon là
par contre a vraiment cherché loin c'est
pas terrible
il a ses limites mais regarder
sérieusement regardez-moi ça juste ça
ces voix là j'ai pas quoi vous dire
d'autre
moi je voudrais vraiment tellement
bluffant l'appareil j'étais chez moi
dans mon jardin il fait nuit noire
il faut se rendre compte que moi avec
mes yeux je ne vois pas je ne vois pas
les transats et je ne vois pas le mur en
face
regardez la lumière que ça vous cap tenu
à la main avec la stabilisation ce que
ça vous sort c'est dingue alors rien par
moment c'est un peu plus difficile mais
la regarder une fois de plus
le ciel les étoiles on y est quoi
franchement alors des photos prises en
plein jour ça fonctionne également aussi
forcément si on sait bien gérer les
photos nues et les photos plein jour ça
va être évident on se rapproche x 2 x 5
x 10 et on en faut 10 et là jusqu'à x
120 x 120 on sait comment ça fonctionne
plus et c'est pas là ce que vous voyez
là eh bien c'est ce que vous avez ici là
derrière dans le bâtiment non de
regarder quand même quoi malgré tout ça
reste bluffant photo de celle fut bon
voilà on est dans l'algorithme qu'on
retrouve usuellement chéchia omis bon
rien de bien dingue là dessus c'est
parce qu'il marchera mieux il ya des
moments il va bien des moyens peu plus
de mal sur les contre jours on retourne
un petit peu faire un tour sur des
scènes urbaines
on voit bien le détail dans le ciel on
voit bien tout sur l'ultra grand temps
que vous avez la lumière ça marche bien
on se rapproche x 2 on se rapproche x 10
x 120 bon voilà c'est vraiment histoire
de se marrer mais une fois de plus il ya
une homogénéité
ça marche bien la gestion des couleurs
et très très bien vous avez vraiment
rendu qui est qui et personnellement
voilà moi je suis vraiment très fâcheux
qui l'ont fait vraiment super boulot sur
ce smartphone la sas et regardez là vous
voyez la tête la gare sage et oryx eh
ben c'est lui là tout au fond voilà
juste ça et même sur le mode portrait
avec mon bon vieux pote l'airé et ben
alors là c'est la spa du mode portrait
de votre portrait il est juste là ça
fonctionne pas mal il a du mal à elle a
eu du mal
voilà c'est un peu la limite du truc
avec le bord de la lune est ici il l'a
perdue donc celui à bouffer un bull
lunettes
voilà c'est un peu les limites du
système ici aussi l'envoi qu'il est un
tout petit peu de mal sur le côté mais
sinon c'est un hâle toujours sur deux
des plantes en extérieur ça marche la
luminosité très bonne les couleurs sont
très bonnes
le 120 c'est vraiment histoire de se
marrer la plage dynamique et très bonne
ultra-grand-angle en dessous de mais une
fois de plus c'est anormal dans ses
smartphones là on va chercher le panneau
chien tout au fond là bas là mais on
arrive à la voir ça fonctionne ok me
voyez moi et mes mêmes avec nos petits
chiens et même un petit roxy bargach
c'est quand même plutôt sympa rsa lui
qu'est ce que vous faites là vous
regarde et vois la même sphère du du
mime de chiens il est en plus ip68 vous
avez du nfc pour le paiement
dématérialisé sans doute rare on a du
wifi si c'est ce qu'on attend en grand
minimum d'un smartphone dans ceux de
gamme de cris à 1200 euros parce que oui
si vous avez une seule config douzy'k
abraham 256 go
le stockage à 1199 euros à 1200 euros
alors moi c'est un smartphone que je
trouve extrêmement surprenants le format
est énorme
il ira vraiment pas pour tout le monde
pour quelques personnes qui veulent
vraiment un très très gros smartphone
est vraiment un truc est énorme pourquoi
pas mais là où il est fort et là où il
est très très fort ce déjà au niveau de
la performance il en coûte quand même
plus loin et surtout mais surtout c'est
les photos de nuit alors on voit
qu'effectivement il ya un traitement
algorithmique derrière qui l'avenir
optimisé pour tous vous faire ressortir
on voit effectivement qu'on a des
capteurs qui sont sur optimisé on voit
que toutes les chaînes de valeur et sur
optimisé que ce soit d'un point de vue
captation avec les capteurs que ce soit
les objectifs que ce soit les capteurs
daria que ce soit tout l'algorithme qui
moulinent derrière que ce soit la
performance avec le cndd règles 888 ce
smartphone là il est très atypique il ne
sera pas fait pour tout le monde
clairement non et même s'ils n'étaient
pas très cher il ne serait pas fait pour
tout le monde parce qu'il est beaucoup
trop gros mais au delà du prix au delà
de tout ça au delà du format je tiens
vraiment à saluer l'expérience en termes
de photos là dessus on l'est sur le top
score de dxo marque
on est à 100 43 c'est aujourd'hui à
l'heure à laquelle je fais la vidéo le
meilleur photophone du marché voilà je
crois qu'il a rien d'autre à dire donc
excellent produit très performant pour
des photos il est magnifique pour lier
midi les tops le grand écran c'est
génial
l'expérience audio est un peu en dessous
et ça c'est dommage il aurait dû
continuer ce qu'il avait fait venir avec
le met dix pros ça aurait été beaucoup
plus loin ça aurait été vraiment presque
un sans-faute ça pour moi c'est une
erreur et c'est vraiment dommage qu'ils
aient fait ça
à côté de ça le smartphone et hop il est
magnifique il marche bien il est sage et
voilà que dire de plus que iard de plus
je sais pas je ne sais pas a vous de me
dire vous ce que vous en pensez en bas
en commentaire comment vous le trouvez
ce smartphone il n'est pas parfait il
est très cher mais franchement il
déchire